samedi à 15h15 sur public sénat
françois bayrou le président du modem le
mouvement démocrate est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous françois hollande a
épuisé son crédit auprès de vous du coup
vous revoilà à la tête nos vastes
chantiers la reconstitution de la
famille du centre avec jean louis borloo
vous nous donnerez
certainement au cours de cette émission
la date du mariage en approche le
constat vous paraîtra cruelle par
ailleurs françois bayrou c'est marine le
pen qui a réussi à faire exploser la
bipolarisation en france en imposant en
tous les cas c'est ce que disent les
sondages le front national comme premier
parti de france à vérifier bien sûr lors
des prochains scrutins
les municipales et surtout les élections
européennes avec moi ce soir raphaël
hermano de l' agence france-presse notre
partenaire avec dailymotion et puis
perrine tarneaud bien sûr de public
sénat pour la troisième partie de
l'émission vos critiques se font tu as
herbe françois bayrou contre la
politique engagée maintenant depuis 18
mois est ce que vous avez atteint un
point de non retour après avoir voté
pour françois hollande
j'ai fait crédit à françois hollande
pendant 18 mois en pensant qu'il
tiendrait les promesses qu'il avait
faites parce que ce sont ces ses phrases
ces mots
le
la politique économique au service de
l'entreprise la politique de l'offre
le retour à l'équilibré le fait qu'en
2013 les finances publiques retombé au
dessous de 3% et le fait qu'il allait
entreprendre la moralisation des gens
qui sont engagés publie non non non les
chantiers ne sont pas engager les
réformes promises ne sont pas au rendez
vous il n'est que de voir on a voté cet
après-midi la réforme des retraites
qui peut soutenir qu'il ya une réforme
des retraites en france la personne de
la thur durée de cotisation est un
fender utilise en 2000 pour les
générations de 5
c'est à peu près ça
alors que tout le monde attendait qu'on
ait une
vraie décision de rebâtir un système des
retraites qui soit juste
égalitaire est assurée dans le long
terme alors vous parlez des retraites
vous en parle aussi du budget puisque la
conversation le débat arrive également à
l'assemblée nationale mais vous vous le
voyez on de dire la conversation
voyez qu'en cohérence dans la politique
suivie mais quand même regardons les
chiffres
qui apparaissent lors des débats 10
milliards de ponction supplémentaire sur
les ménages 10 milliards d'allègements
sur les entreprises là il ya
manifestement une cohérence le cap
économique et de fixer c'est la
politique de l'avenue je vous auriez
fait sur les noms j'aurais pas du tout
agir comme ça sur les ménages 15
milliards de de ponction supplémentaire
on peut pas prétendre que ce soit allé
dans le sens que les français souhaitent
et que on leur avait dit alors je vais
vous dire je vais vous dis non non
je vais vous dire ce qu'est ma man
divergences fondamentales avec françois
hollande avec pour moi il est impossible
de faire des économies si on ne fait pas
des réformes de fond
c'est pas en essayant de couper ici ou
là des des petits millimètres de
dépenses publiques voire quelques
millions ici ou là que vous arriverez à
faire les économies qui se comptent en
dizaines de milliards
vous ne pouvez arriver à ces économies
là que si vous avez
reconstruit une action publique qui doit
être à la fois moins onéreuse et
permettez moi de vous demander d'écouter
bien la deuxième
moitié de cette phrase c'est quoi qui
est plus efficace
parce que ce qui est très frappant quand
on regarde l'action publique de notre
pays à la fois état collectivités
locales sécu c'est qu'elle est très cher
et très peu efficaces ou en tout cas
moins efficace qu'on ne pourrait
l'espérer fondamentale qui se fait pas
en un claquement de doigts oui mais il
n'y a eu ni commencement
ni
projection de l'avenir il n'y a pas eu
de plans d'architecte
quand on reconstruit maison fait un plan
d'architecte
rien de tout ça traire
on accroît encore tous les défauts du
système je vais citer un exemple qui
tient à la maison où vous êtes
c'est-à-dire au sénat et donc
collectivités locales des rares choses
que j'approuvais vraiment dans le
gouvernement précédent c'était l'idée
qu' on allait simplifier les
collectivités locales départements et
régions aux particuliers en ayant un
seul type d'élu pour les deux assemblées
vous vous souvenez que c'est l'idée que
j'avais proposée dès 2002 qui avait été
peu à peu reprises par le gouvernement
précédent hors cat ont fait eh bien on a
supprimé cette simplification pour
revenir encore un peu plus de complexité
dans un système un coûte de plus en plus
cher et qui est de moins en moins
visibles par le citoyen j'entends toutes
vos critiques françois bayrou a
maintenant vous pouvez répondre à la
question initiale est ce que vous avez
atteint un point de non-retour vis-à-vis
de françois l'enjeu n'est de jugement
par rapport à l'action des gouvernants
qu'en fonction de ce qu'ils font si un
jour françois hollande ou le
gouvernement prend une attitude que je
trouverai une attitude positive je le
dirai quand il disait je vais faire une
comédie de l'homme quand il disait je
vais faire une politique de l'offre elle
est approuvée quand il a dit prenons ne
cesserait revendique aujourd'hui ont-ils
a dit pas c'est difficile de tenir ce
discours là quand on est de gauche et
bien prenons un autre exemple
il avait dit au printemps au mois de mai
je crois et je l'avais à prouver qu' il
allait mettre en place
proposer immédiatement havre est une
vraie intégration politique de la zone
euro et qu'il y aurait une décision
politique qui porterait sur la zone euro
ou qui prendrait en compte les intérêts
de la zone euro et je lai a prouvé de le
faire est-ce que de le dire est ce que
ça a été fait vous qui êtes un
observateur en attendant c'est ce qu'il
voulait seulement qu'il n'a pas tenus
par ailleurs j'aime dans vos échanges je
conversais ce jamais
j'y viens dans une seconde mais
est ce qu il a fait quoi que ce soit
dans le sens de cette affirmation que je
considérais comme une affirmation
positive rien n'a été fait on n'a pas
déposé un plan sur la table du conseil
européen on s'est contenté comme chaque
fois d'une déclaration purement verbale
que les français intéressés par le sujet
pouvait approuver et qui n'a été suivie
de rien pourquoi en effet le frein
majeur c'est sa majorité présidentielle
il aurait dû vous appeler don jose
aurait été possible figurez vous que je
ne fonctionne pas en termes de
marchandage
alors peut-être je suis minoritaire dans
la classe politique française mais
jamais je ne marchande pas ce que je
trouve que c'est dégradant c'est
dévalorisant il ya quelque chose qui ne
qui ne va pas de ce point de vue là et
donc à leurs programmes ce n'est pas le
marchand devaient non mais c'est pas du
tout ce qui a été fait en revanche
chaleureux il y avait une promesse
explicite que françois hollande avait
fait quand il m'a écrit entre les deux
tours comme nicolas sarkozy m'avait
écrit cette promesse explicite c'était
qu'il ferait la grande loi de
moralisation de la vie publique dont la
france avait besoin et il avait ajouté
quelque chose d'autre qui était que s'il
y avait des freins au parlement
devant le cumul des mandats devant le
financement de la vie publique devant je
ne sais quoi toutes les opérations
nécessaires
alors ils iraient au référendum du
peuple français quand at il fait alors
rien et on constate et je ne sais pas si
vous avez remarqué françois bayrou mais
des responsables socialistes et non des
moindres vous regrette aujourd'hui
françois rebsamen le patron des
sénateurs socialistes et à votre place
il ya quelques semaines il a dit il a
regretté que des gestes envers vous
n'ait pas été fait et puis manuel valls
juge embêtant votre départ de la
majorité présidentielle c'est comme ça
que l'express présente les choses cette
semaine le ministre d'intérieur dès que
françois hollande avait plutôt envie de
faire des gestes en votre direction
qu'est ce que vous répondez
regrets non je pense qu'il ya une erreur
de de perspectives
je n'ai jamais soutenu où je n'ai jamais
apporté ou donner du crédit à françois
hollande en fonction de gestes pas
besoin de gestes je suis un responsable
politique qui étalèrent exemple atouts
physiques manquons et mines candidat
socialiste en face de vous en
législatives de l'an dernier c'est trop
tard maintenant évidemment c'est facile
mais
donc il regrette de vous voir partir
mais je n'en jeu en opposition que
répondez-vous à fukushima n'est ce pas
une bonne idée en tête c'est que je n'ai
jamais changé de ligne j'ai fait crédit
en attendant que le gouvernement et le
pouvoir
accomplissez changer de pied un coma
laissez moi n'ont en aucune manière à
bon et je voudrais que vous si vous le
pouvez que vous entendiez sur un agent
vous dit
j'ai un certain nombre de certitudes sur
ce qu'il faut faire pour la france
les années précédentes étaient des
années am à mon avis de d'inquiétantes
glissement des rives et je pensais que
françois hollande allait respecter les
engagements qu'il avait pris je pensais
même qu'il avait sur ce sujet des atouts
particuliers que les autres n'avaient
pas d'abord parce qu'il était plus en
phase avec le monde syndical par exemple
ils pouvaient proposer des réformes plus
ambitieuses et puis c'était un pouvoir
nouveau après beaucoup d'années de
difficultés je pensais qu'il avait des
êtres unis malgré la grille et ses 1 tc
a tout à mon avis ne les a pas joués
alors vous demander pourquoi c'est
intéressant comme question je pense
parce qu'il a les yeux trop fixé sur sa
majorité cloud pense que ce qui les
intéresse ce qu'il a en tête ce qui le
le haut tout le perturbe ce sont les
états d'âme des courants du parti qui le
soutient et des alliés du parti knk
soutien et des satellites du parti qu'il
soutient et je pense que c'est une
erreur de conception de la fonction
présidentielle pour faire voler en
éclats non mais écoutez moi bien il est
président de la république il n'est
apparu majeur et grenier ministre il
n'est pas premier ministre c'est le
premier ministre qui s'occupe de la
majorité d'accord le dans les
institutions de la vème république le
chef de la majorité c'est le premier
ministre est toujours dans les
institutions de la vème république
l'homme qui s'occupe du pays et pas du
parti des enjeux du pays pas de la
communication mais du fond c'est le
président de la république et pour moi
il n'est pas il ne relève il n'a pas
pris à bâle à bras le corps la
responsabilité présidentielle comme il
aurait dû le faire avec cette vision qui
est celle que
qui s'imposent lorsque leur peuple vous
a donné sa confiance le peuple justement
vous avez vu nouveau record
d'impopularité pour le chef de l'état
24% d'opinions favorables selon ipsos
seulement parce que cela pose la
question de la légitimité de l'exécutif
question que pose par exemple
l'ump christian jacob non je trouve
ridicules les accusations réciproques de
l'ump du ps sur vous êtes responsable de
marine le pen disent les uns ou bien
vous avez perdu toute légitimité et
disent les autres c'est à une critique
quand même dit bruno le maire attendu
qu'elle ça devient difficile de
gouverner lire et encore plus de
réformes et il y à un seuil critique au
dessous duquel il est très difficile de
gouverner ça n'est pas une raison pour
faire un procès en légitimité parce que
évidemment sauna ça n'a aucun sens je
vais vous dire ce que je pense de la
popularité pour moi la bcrg d'ailleurs
vu changement de pied
oui moi l'impopularité ça n'a aucune
importance si on fait des choses
qui comptent
il arrive que des
gouvernants
doivent assumer l'impopularité si ils
font pour leur pays ce qui doit être
fait des choses importantes lourde qui
probablement dérange mais ils le font
mais l'impopularité quand on ne fait pas
ce qu'il faut faire alors ça c'est très
embêtant et ça empêche de pouvoir entrer
dans l'action politique la plus profonde
celle qui pour l'instant n'est pas
conduite alors on va parler du centre de
l'extrême droite également vous l'avez
évoqué d'un mot françois bayrou avec le
rafale hermano de l' agence
france-presse qui va nous rejoindre
l'élection de brignoles mark en effet
l'avènement apparemment du triple du
tripartisme c'est en tous les cas ce que
dit le socialiste jean christophe
cambadélis et c'est vous faut-il le
rappeler qu'ils poursuivent y ait ce but
mettre fin au bipartisme et bien marine
le pen semble y parvenir sophie normand
ni droite ni gauche françois bayrou
voulait faire éclater le bipartisme et
se poser en troisième homme mais voilà
que marine le pen vient lui ravir la
place en témoigne la victoire du front
national à brignoles dimanche dernier ce
qui est intéressant c'est pas tellement
la victoire électorale du front national
c'est que le front national s'est mis au
centre de la vie politique française et
qui va être l'enjeu des prochaines
élections et partisme le mot est lâché
marine le pen sincère peu à peu dans le
clivage gauche droite et évince françois
bayrou de l'échiquier politique
en politique on hérite jamais de rien
les places qu'on a c'est ça le comprend
et françois bayrou a perdu la sienne à
gauche comme à droite de manuel valls à
françois fillon le fn est devenu une
obsession selon le mot de sa présidente
marine le pen qui peut s'appuyer sur un
parti solide là où françois bayrou a
échoué son capital politique c'est
uniquement la notoriété qu'il avait
acquise à la fois en tant que ancien
candidat du centre à l'élection
présidentielle en 2002 et d'autre part
sa critique du sarkozysme
une seule solution pour faire éclater le
bipartisme la prochaine élection
présidentielle françois bayrou aura-t-il
l'audace de se présenter une nouvelle
fois réponse dans quatre ans
voilà raphaël hermano est avec nous
rappelle bonsoir en question à françois
bayrou françois bayrou bonjour fin du
tripartisme marine le pen a réussi là où
vous avez échoué donc en aucune manière
le ce que je me suis fixé comme but dans
la vie politique c'est que notre pays
puisse prendre les décisions qui
s'imposent et retrouvé par son action
propre son indépendance sa liberté de
manoeuvre le le rayonnement qui devrait
être le sien la richesse pour ses
concitoyens l'avenir pour ces jeunes et
l'emploi
et si vous me dites que c'est ce que
marine le pen apporte à la france alors
permettez-moi de le dire
parmi les objectifs il y avait celui de
peu d'en face confondez pas partie comme
fond d'histoire à mes shoes vous
confondez quelque chose qui est qui est
presque navrant il faut faire attention
vous confondez les moyens et les fins et
les bus le but c'est que notre pays se
porte mieux pour qu'ils se portent mieux
il faut qu'il puisse faire une politique
de réformes pour qu'il fasse une
politique de réforme il faut qu'il ait
une majorité différente de celle qui est
la sienne aujourd'hui
vous dire ça gentiment et avec beaucoup
de respect naturellement pour l'éminente
fonctions et les qualités hors du commun
qui sont les vôtres femmes journalistes
mais
vous êtes je crois fasciné par les
sondages qu'obtiennent les uns ou les
autres ça n'est pas la bonne moins que
d'autres ça n'est pas la bonne dont je
parle pas de vous aussi
ça nous aura pas élection on voit bien
élection après élection que le front
national gagne du terrain donc la
question se pose légitimement de savoir
si on arrive vers et bien si tu as eu
permettez moi de poser la question
différente la question différemment
excusez moi c'est que la seule question
qui se pose c'est est-ce que ce que vous
décrivez est bon pour le pays ou mauvais
pour le pays ça c'est vous qui répondent
non non nous avons à répondre tous sens
citoyen ceux des citoyens comme les
autres il ya eu tout un temps où les
journalistes
éditorialisé comme on dit sont ce genre
de sujet est là pour vous écouter
ce que vous dites on a l'impression que
vous jugez au fond que la presse
notamment parle peut-être trop du front
national est ce que c est ce que ça mais
ça c'est autre chose et fascination non
mais non sans doute oui mais ça n'est
pas le sujet le sujet c'est que les
responsables politiques eux en tout cas
ne perdent pas de vue la seule question
qui se pose est ce que tout ça nous
amène à du mieux ou est ce que tout ça
nous amène à du pire et bien pour moi la
réponse est sans ambiguïté
ça nous amène à de graves accidents
parce que pour deux raisons très très
importante la première vous savez que
j'ai eu de longs débats avec nicolas
sarkozy sur ce sujet la responsabilité
première d'un chef d'état ou d'un homme
politique majeure la responsabilité
première c'est l'unité de son pays de
son peuple
si il dresse les uns contre les autres
il rend le pire des services à son pays
là vous accréditent s'accréditer a
presque dit courir parce que j'avais pas
fini comme j'ai dit et j'ai eu l'air de
vous estimez que effectivement c'est des
rebelles l'ump a sa part de
responsabilité dans la poussée du front
national dans sa part de responsabilité
vous avez été très dur pendant la
campagne de nicolas sarkozy sur la
droite et masque il j'ai jamais employé
le mot droitisation non mais vous avez à
ce que le mot droitisation voudrait dire
que la droite c'est mal et je n'ai
jamais pensé moi que la droite c'était
mal car il ya une droite que je
considère et des valeurs de droite que
je considère comme absolument honorable
l'honneur le sens du travail le
dévouement
le sentiment que au fond on est
responsable de son propre destin pour
faire ça sur l'identité nationale par
exemple vous n'en vouliez pas non mais
est-ce que vous poserez la question
différemment est ce que l'ump est ce que
l'ump petit à petit atta a banalisé les
idées du front national de
bon vous voyez bien qu'il ya une course
que que tout le monde va les combats
politiques ont toujours lieu à la
frontière entre deux forces et donc
comme le combat est à la frontière en
masse les troupes à la frontière et
comme on masse les troupes à la
frontière et bien on se base sur les
mots même les idées mêmes qui sont
celles de l'adversaire le plus voisins
et donc de ce point de vue là oui il ya
cette emprise mais je n'ai jamais
employé le mot de droitisation accord et
donc je veux je veux simplement revenir
à la deuxième partie de la question est
donc la première partie c'était sa
division il ya une deuxième part de
responsabilité qui je considère qui fait
que je considère que le front national
conduit non pas du mieux mais du pire
c'est que les idées qu'ils propagent
sont des idées mortel si on se mêlaient
de les appliquer par exemple la france
hors de l'europe elle sort de l'euro
elle
elle renvoie on voit pas bien comment
les immigrés elle supprime et bien tout
cela pour moi
je pense que ça conduit à de graves
accidents et donc voilà les deux pôles
qui font que pour ma part je suis en
effet en absolu opposition assez cette
force alors ça pose par ailleurs la
question du front républicain on a vu
qu'il avait plus que du plomb dans l
aile à l'occasion de cette élection de
brignoles est ce que vous vous y êtes
toujours favorables ou est-ce qu'il est
mort définitivement enterré je sais pas
ce que c'est parce que tout le monde
annonce e semaine après semaine que le
front républicain c'est fini
l'ump a dit plus jamais de front
républicain il m'a semblé que à
brignoles il espérait d'avoir avoir les
voix de gauche n'est ce pas oui bon et
donc il y avait là comme une
contradiction
certains ténors il y avait des visions
dans n'ya pas division se transcendent
révélé réflexe de nous aurait voulu
ils ont eu beaucoup de voix de gauche
c'est même ce qui a permis la remontée
de la candidate mais je pense qu'en
effet il ya quelque chose d'eux
devrait et qui n'est pas en tort au
moins en terme de messages qui n'est pas
un bon message c'est de dire tous contre
le front national
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est tous contre
les causes du front national est la
première des causes du front national
c'est l'impuissance dans laquelle les
deux majorités successives haute autour
des deux partis principaux successifs
s'est trouvé enfermé l'absence de
résultats comme dit françois hollande
c'est même pas de résultats c'est
l'absence de
décision si des décisions courageuses
avaient été prises on pourrait parler
des résultats mais aucune décision
courageuse de prix alors à propos des
forêts publiques à l'injure de vous
demander françois bayrou ce que vous
faites en cas de duel hollande marine le
pen je n'ai aucune intention de me
placer dans l'hypothèse d'un duel
hollande marine le pen que je trouve
aujourd'hui très improbable avant pour
refuser de répondre et je vous voyez que
tous les responsables publics que vous
inviter à cette table qui rendent
spontanément bien et bien moi ce que je
souhaite avec avec
constance c'est qu'on ne se trouve pas
dans ce type d' hypothèse est envisagé
l'hypothèse c'est accréditer l'hypothèse
vous voyez le un monsieur que qu'est ce
que vous ferez en cas de duel je ne sais
pas mélenchon marine le pen est bien
excusez moi de vous dire que je trouve
l'hypothèse peu crédible et je n'ai pas
envie d'une manière ou d'une autre
d'accréditer cette hypothèse est donc je
leur fais de ton nom ne voulait pas
répondre je trouve que on n'a pas à se
placer dans les hypothèses de questions
d'accord que vous posez sous sa défense
et votre nom réponse raphael au delà du
fn il ya aussi le centre vous en tant
que patron du modem vous êtes en train
de vous rapprocher de lui dit que
jean-louis borloo
l'une inverse où la caf d'abord il n'y a
pas une petite contradiction après tout
ce que vous avez dit sur nicolas sarkozy
pendant cinq ans à vous rapprocher de
quelqu'un qui a été l'un de ses
principaux ministres pendant trois ans
il a même failli être son premier
ministre ont failli alors revenons une
seconde à ce que vous dites pour qu'on
voit si ça tient 1 vous n'ignorez pas
que j'ai de très bonnes relations avec
alain juppé
vous n'êtes pas lui plaire ça ne vous
étonne pas travailler va nager a été
ministre des affaires étrangères de
nicolas sarkozy je ne considère pas qui
est le la moindre contamination des uns
par les autres il était rare qu ise quoi
jean louis borloo c'est moi non mais
c'est pas ça la question la question est
que je n'ai dans ma vie eu qu'un plan
politique pour que cette majorité
nouvelle puisse apparaître que la
politique nouvelle puisse être faite il
faut qu' un centre en france à condition
que ce centre soit indépendant sûrs de
ce qu'ils pensent et jean louis borloo
ayant quitté l'ump et tous ceux qui
l'entourent 10 ans en font maintenant
avec sans abandonner ses alliances avait
on a le droit d'avoir des alliances on a
le droit la seule condition c'est que
les alliances ne soient pas automatiques
quelles que soient les décisions et les
orientations prises moi je je je n'ai
aucune difficulté à avoir des alliances
avec la droite c'est pourquoi on veut
savoir maintenant
pardonnez moi mais je trouve que les il
faut choisir les mots et franchement
entre jean louis borloo et moi ce
ce vocabulaire matrimoniale
autrement non mais le le rapprochement
la construction d'une maison commune qui
est nécessaire pour que les deux
familles du centre puisse vivre et
travailler ensemble ben j'espère que
c'est dans les dix jours qui viennent
parler des gens apprennent à ça
prendrait quelle forme y aura vous
verrez on vous invitera vous serez
content vous découvrirez comme ça ça
vous permet de faire des hypothèses
d'imaginer ce qu'on pourrait faire
d'être surpris par la simplicité des
choses de goût par exemple sur les
européennes comment est-ce que ça va se
passer il y aura des listes communes udi
modem à le la première décision qui
découle de cet accord ou de ce
rapprochement s'est évidemment qui est
des listes communes entre
les deux familles du municipal c'est
comment parce que là c'est un peu
différent avec
l'accord à peu près sur 90% des sur 90%
des villes et 10% c'est là vous avez
vous des alliances avec la gauche non ce
n'est pas ça dépend il ya des cas où
nous avons des listes nous sur des
communes y compris qui nous
appartiennent et où lui dit jusqu'à
maintenant était dans une alliance avec
l'ump on peut discuter de c2c de serre
configuration mais vous conserverez des
alliances à gauche pour les prochaines
municipales on peut citer dehors des
villes lille
les gens au camp aura besoin de vous
garder son volet jusqu'à maintenant n'a
été décidé a et donc je vais vous dire
les choses comme je le pense depuis
longtemps je pense que ceux qui
devraient gouverner les élections
locales c'est la personnalité des
responsables locaux élections locales du
deal va l'entendre ben on a on a des
discussions il ya des réglages c'est
tout à fait normal à paris comment ça va
se passer est ce que marielle de sarnez
va être sur une liste derrière higuain
vous lui poserez la question
la raison moi j'ai quelques idées mais
je pense que je pense que ce que
marielle de sarnez fait précisément dans
la logique de ce que sur quoi vous
m'interrogez c'est rassembler le centre
pour qu'il pèse à paris et après je
pense qu'elle envisage y compris des
rassemblements plus large mais c'est
elle qui le dira c'est pas moi est ce
que vous croyez inéluctable des accords
à la base entre l'ump et le front
national vous avez vu ça correspond à la
tente à la demande des sympathisants je
pense qu'il ya une pression très
importante sur ce sujet j'espère que
l'ump y résistera d'ailleurs pas
seulement l'ump il peut y avoir ici ou
là des tentations de ce genre moi en
tout cas je recommanderais et je ferai
tout ce que je peux pour qu'on me
pour qu'on n'y cède pas est ce que une
dérouillée modem vous irait jusqu'à
présenter un candidat commun à la
présidentielle
je vous ai dit que la première décision
qui découle s étaient les européennes et
la deuxième soirée cool et dont elle a
deux noms
faut écouter c'est le le problème de
votre vocation de journaliste c'est que
les questions c'est important mais je
vous dis un secret les réponses aussi
alors à les écouter et donc pour moi je
ne vous dis nullement chaque chose en
son temps je vous dis que dans l'accord
il y aura forcément
l'orientation de présenter un candidat
le jour venu à l'élection présidentielle
bien qu'on ne sache pas qui c'est pour
vous éviter les obsessions
obsession
forcément qui met une grande famille
politique à vocation à présenter un
candidat à l'élection présidentielle ce
soir soyez prêts pour rempiler une prose
quatrième que je n'ai absolument pas ça
dans ma ligne de mire bon maintenant à
plonger quand même je ne vous réponds
non pas dans votre lit ou peut-être 20
dans votre lettre vous entendez parler
ici c'est bien en tant qu'ailier alors
dites-nous vous devez crier ça n'est pas
dans ma ligne avant les européennes
avant la présidentielle il ya donc les
municipales et vous vous replonger enfin
vous partez au combat à pons eh bien
vous avez déjà entendu ma réponse alors
je vais la faire aussi
calmement que possible c'est une affaire
c'est la sphère d'une ville qu'est la
ville de pau qui se trouve elle n'a pas
le droit de mettre la ville dans
laquelle j'ai passé ma vie dans
lesquelles j'ai été
grandi
dans la chaîne de mes enfants de ma
famille a eu sa gyger mais aussi de vous
en faire de l'audience et des villes qui
m'intéressent profondément dont je pense
qu'elle va mal et quand j'aurai à en
parler j'en parlerai à pau aux palois
d'accord à pau très bien quand même pas
faire une petite perle autres fonctions
ump localement non mais du coup elle
l'ump a fait comprendre qu'elle
maintiendrait coûte que coûte une liste
à pau donc en gros ils veulent vous
faire payer le votre transfert la saison
est ce que c est ce que c'est ça qui
vous empêcherait que est ce que vous
vous souvenez que ils ont déjà fait ça
il ya six ans et que ça n'était pas pour
la raison du deuxième tour de 2012 est
donc cet internement et donc je je je
suis à peu près certain que les esprits
sur ce sujet doivent évoluer parce
qu'autrement ça voudrait dire que c'est
la volonté de perdre sept vilains qui
appartient au parti socialiste permettez
moi de vous le dire depuis 42 ans ce qui
fait tout de même un bail